on va parler un peu de
limon c'est une membrane c'est un repli
de la muqueuse vaginale qui se trouve
autour de l'orifice du vagin et parfois
qui bouche plus ou moins l'entrée juste
petit aparté vous avez déjà entendu dire
que quand on a un vagin on saigne
forcément après le premier rapport
sexuel parce qu'il y a un truc qui se
déchire et ce truc qui est censé se
rompre qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
que non pas du tout alors pourquoi
bullshit bah déjà parce que la majorité
des vagins et équipés d'un hymen mais
pas tous et puis ensuite parce que des
emails il y en a de plusieurs tailles de
plusieurs formes différentes plus ou
moins élastiques donc il se déchire pas
forcément parfois il peut juste
s'élargir un peu ou se détendre et donc
l'hyménotomie c'est le fait de couper un
petit peu l'hymen mais attention il y a
plein d'autres raisons qui peuvent
expliquer que les rapports sexuels sont
difficiles donc du coup avant de vous
faire opérer consulter bien un ou une
gynéco pour être sûr que le souci vient
bien de l'hymen n'hésitez pas à prendre
plusieurs